hey I was gonna press my name is
beautiful welcome back to the walking
dead we just met climbing climbing clue
Climaco with the giant girl mob oh [ __ ]
okay here we go
hey stop the truck pretty so she's the
one that did it
[ __ ]
well you almost crushed me in the
process
tree fell slower than I thought it would
put your hands up and close your eyes
she's a badass I'm the victim here we're
all victims oh so it's okay for you to
rob me oh my god you got a shame it for
saving you
hey that's for my niece she loves
chocolate more than anything I promised
it to her please
Oh
clammy she's so cute keep your eyes
closed and count to 100 before you go
waitjust my family I need to get back to
them we were attacked and I don't would
I just need to know where I am we were
driving down the 522 and that's when we
found the junkyard they're still there I
need to get back to them I know where
that is
you said you were driving in our van
yeah I'll take you to the junkyard if
you let me have your van I get you there
in one piece then I Drive away yeah
absolutely you got a deal good let's go
this climate even know how to drive this
really necessary I don't know you
how old is climbing and I'm not taking
any chances so it's safer for both of us
hope you're tied up hope that wasn't a
weird joke I just realized it clearly
was look I get it you're being cautious
glad we understand each other
the name is Xavier by the way people
call me javi
listen I just want to ship them okay
that's all Clementine uh-huh
Clementine cool name if you say so
I prefer voice now actually it's my it's
smoother before it was like a came in
techno it's Clementine it's cool she's
cool
I'm so excited oh whoa what the [ __ ] is
his arm doing
more fall people
climbing wooden waste ammo that's right
she knows how to deal with these guys
right through the [ __ ] map you're
good at that been around look you don't
want to talk fine but how about you give
me the gun back so I can at least defend
myself why is Clementine alone no you
turn around and use it on me look I'm
not gonna shoot you
you shot the other guy well you didn't
tie me up and stick me in a truck well
he's still tied up the herd caught up
with us boys that's one thing that's
really weird to me about the Walking
Dead is that they never refer to them as
zombie it sounded like Walker's the
prowlers or mark toes or prayer toes
walkers Nega what do you call the ones
that run they're all [ __ ] walkers okay
the ones that one I'm not used to being
around other people not for a while
anyway
does that mean they're different types
of walk certainly on my own apology
accepted I wasn't apologizing
so who's at this junkyard my brother's
kids and his wife it's impressive
surviving this long not sure how you did
it
just keeping everyone together like that
okay oh great ever I had to do to
protect me I have to not of trouble the
best I could
thanks that sometimes it's not enough
how about you you must have been pretty
young when this [ __ ] started I was but
some people looked out for me too
what happened to them same thing that
happens to everyone
[ __ ] we can't stay here there's a town
up ahead we can stay there until the
herd passes otherwise we're Walker food
can you do that please fine whatever you
say she clearly knows her way around
she's still wearing the cab don't make
me regret this come on come on okay
we're heading to the fan the giant fan
is it you okay let's keep pain oh it's
about to get intense oh we got some
people
get to the gate it's smashed and
[Music]
okay-y
oh thanks appreciate it I can't open the
gate till you clear them out can't risk
it
nice man fun loser fine all right
boom bin but zinga zinga head shut all
around now what don't worry clay me I
got you let's see it Clemmy you're fine
[ __ ] yeah claim oh my god buddies
Oceanside come on now [ __ ] [ __ ]
god effing damn it Francine one of these
days those doors are gonna close and
your ass will be on the other side what
is happening now when that day comes
trip I promise
I'll eat you first ha ha it's Clementine
right you stay in a while this time no
once the walkers pass I'm taking this
guy to a junkyard off the highway my
family might be trapped they're hiding
from some very bad dudes well [ __ ] I am
truly sorry to hear that
Makana sir me as a badass quick we're
hoping it's gone just as fast so just
keep your heads down and steer clear of
trouble you got me there's too much
going on outside the walls tonight will
be cool just need a place to ride out
the herd that's all all right I'm gonna
hold you to that and I wouldn't
recommend changing your mind if you hang
on doll your tea set is head on in
I got [ __ ] to do the walkers I mean the
Sam welcome to Prescott
they walk it they moving hurts and
there's all cities around now even or
out pose that's pretty cool pretty cool
place actually the world air strip I
guess looks like a very fallout II the
people on the other hand they're not my
favorite usually I'm in and out as quick
as I can manage no no this place is
actually kind of charming it's got walls
all the way around and well that thing
yeah like I said this is a pretty cool
place it's called a silo thank you very
much
hoo-ee then what's up
clearly is worried about his family
they're still out there what is that
guy's made it this long I'm sure you
know they'll know what to do hopefully
let's go this way okay bullets okay she
bought the bullet on the gun and clearly
didn't work huh this is very cool I'm
much more intrigued by this universe I
haven't been in a place like this well
you know it's just like the old days
listen I gotta take care of something
hang tight wait wait what should I do
I don't know why don't you make some
friends she's so cute
I'm the new Lee huh this is great I'd
really enjoy this let's look at these
guys why not uh-huh
play your hand you're gonna lose but you
don't have to do it in slow motion
don't try and rush me I know you again
this is my game clearly always a
smartass
well it ain't going work they look so
nice what is he what is Clementine
meaning with the people here excuse me
ah you again you got some moves I'll
give you that hold on to me don't I know
you from somewhere I don't know maybe
Garcia Javier Garcia but what is worth I
think you got screwed on the gambling
thing a lifetime ban [ __ ] what does that
mean
it had a 20 year career the way I see it
nothing wrong with betting on yourself
to win we just got a lifetime ban now
they just wanted to set an example
I was the poor bastard they used to do
it on all I know is what I read in the
papers we used to be famous from
gambling I'm Conrad this is Francine he
runs the place I just take his money
yeah well maybe I'm just letting you win
actually if you're the gamblin type
games poker five-card stud
I'll raise you what do you think should
I call should have fold well I'm the
expert Ryan don't get too intimidated I
lose more often than I care to admit
call his bluff
he's bluffing he's got [ __ ] written
all over is that a fact
I think I'll listen to the man call
moment of truth flipper
oh my ain't that a pretty sight
hey hell yeah
nice calm down both are the advanced huh
hey on my tab
whoa Wow this smells like turpentine
that's the weak stuff don't turn away
from me I'm talking to you [ __ ]
climbing she's so cool hey what's the
point in talking what I already told you
what deal is a deal and it's done what's
going on guy ripped me off I traded him
a crate of perfectly good batteries and
he gave me a box of bullets that won't
fire he could have gotten both of us
killed
yeah and who the [ __ ] are you a
bodyguard or something he looks like
such a cuz I don't scare easy all right
she doesn't need a bot right right a
person she could take care of herself
believe me well you can't even prove
those the bullets I traded you oh wait
come on
he knows the bullets don't work listen
to it he's not even nervous I could have
died because of his bullets I'm [ __ ]
boy look out
whoa [ __ ] listen let's all cool down huh
you were acting crazy I was too we just
got a little out of hand
that's all just give me what I'm owed
Jesus you've got to get her under
control man they say no way to do
business
oh you have a wrong buddy I don't
controller which looks like bad news for
you we had a deal all right hey okay all
right so babe we'll trade back I'll find
some battery don't need batteries Oh
drop the gun right now he attacked you
and that he was going for his gun oh
[ __ ] the war I attacked him I only shot
because shut it you done enough talking
drop it there's a hurt out there and
you're firing off a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] happened here okay self-defense
enough from you does she really have to
shoot
look at my eye man of course she's
telling the truth the guy ripped her off
reached for his gun and would have shot
me if she hadn't stopped him see you
happy now god damn it
I'm putting you two under lock and key
until I figure out what to do oh hey hey
what are you for real as real as it gets
now move it see Banias isn't coming in
you're [ __ ] up my bar doesn't seem
that bad you know at least they're safe
[Music]
about a punch your [ __ ] lights out
both of you
but Eli was a great a certified [ __ ]
I'll even have someone come take a look
at that cut thing what a service hey
thanks for having my back at the hangar
that was um that was cool of you
I wasn't sure there for a minute of
course any time how I mean you and I are
a team now we've always been I mean it
just don't think this makes us friends
or anything okay hello oh hello I'm
Eleanor I'm what passes for a doctor
around here a trip sort of over does it
sometimes I hate that I'm treating you
in a cage like you're some feral animal
Javier pleasures all mine
and then now now let's see about that
whoa yeah
yeah he got you good try to hold still
ah why is it always the pretty ones who
end up causing the most trouble behavior
or something are you calling me pretty
hmm I was talking about LA today oh yeah
good because I prefer dashing or
debonair maybe oh ho I'll try mind met
group claims just sleeping on the wagon
blower people are saying she killed a
man in cold blood if you don't mind me
asking what did happen exactly that they
were arguing and then she went crazy
over nothing look things got out of hand
Clementine was only trying to make a
point but then you make it sound so
casual that thing that's probably for
you J to leave town and get back to your
group we were a wild where's the singing
there were four of us oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
if there's there's anything I can do to
help not that I have much to offer you
but I know a thing or two about losing
family hey it's okay you've done enough
I hear you but Eleanor you done yet
just about all right here's what we're
gonna do I'm dropping you just about
myself get you out of my hair and no one
can say I didn't do right by no one in
the meantime you two could sleep right
here and think about what [ __ ] you
were earlier on my Charlie guy and on my
timeline you got me all right fingernail
on it fair enough go kiss a skunk's ass
I should be earning a goddamn Boy Scout
badge for this trip it doesn't seem
right to wait javis people they could
need a medic
no no way not putting you in that kind
of danger again that's not your call
look maybe there's another way we've got
a rear gate tell me the other into the
airfield we don't use it much Bend well
we could leave tonight she likes heard
get a jump start on reaching that
junkyard your family does need help I'll
be right there to give it what seriously
you'd do that for me it's just it's the
right thing to do
anyway think about it I've got to check
on some patients but I'll be back in an
hour
you know I never would have guessed she
had a dinner yeah she's she's something
the thing is and maybe this sounds weird
but I still trust trip more than I trust
her
I would I I would trust I trust I trust
Clementine more than I trust anyone okay
I've been with her why should I trust
Eleanor I'll go I'll go with you Fred
clementines that drifts got more muscle
just in case we'll wait and get a ride
with him no I finally listening to
reason even though I really like a girl
when I met you I thought you'd just be
another [ __ ] like everyone else and
to think that when we first met you
nearly blew my head off yeah guess I
made the right call it's gonna be a
while before that herd passes we might
as well get some sleep good I already
had her sleep I'm exhausted
I'll get the lamp
oh oh [ __ ] got dark for a sec there what
the [ __ ] just happened what that [ __ ] it
is surely the booty
[Music]
what is this hey what'd you draw on
their goofball
can I see oh you know I'm no good at
this game Rex I'll try to guess what it
is
just give me a second I'll figure it out
it's me me it is me I knew it come on
can you say Clem AJ give it a try
Clem not much of a talker baby of course
Edith says you should be speaking by now
but don't worry about it you'll talk
when you're ready that was weird
clam open up it's me Edith what's wrong
the group from last week they're back
and now they're armed this is bad Clem
there's a lot of them too many of them
I don't like the looks of it what do
they want from us but more than we can
give and and now they're angry because
she was training to make me lick be
ready to run just yes they got a lot of
cars and they're seriously pissed off
this is good sauce
just Tomatoes after stuff when I get
back we gotta get the hell out [ __ ]
bare essentials come on we [ __ ] thank
you man
our people are sick and starving it
didn't have to be this way you could
have just given us some grub some
medicine that's it this is your fault
y'all are just warning it for your
Kenny's head club club they're inside we
have to go now
whoa this is Wellington yeah yeah holy
[ __ ] give me a J Oh
oh my god okay you're okay what happened
to AJ then we don't know yet we don't
know yet Oh
Clement hey Clem we almost there
hey date day - yeah we're close I gotta
say I hope your people are safe and
sound Eleanor asked me before we left to
make sure of it
oh yeah yes sir that's what I'm gonna do
oh why she went to bat for you and I've
got no idea I mean she hardly even knows
you and you don't know her for that
matter well what's the matter you
jealous I just I got a natural curiosity
that's all got'em I mean at this point I
don't even care if the other guys are
still there like I'm not invested enough
in them I don't really give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a mess
Jesus I don't know what we expand roots
of them gates good in a crisis that was
one of I mean that was one of that
wasn't that hers
godom my chocolate the cassette player
iana's tape player
mariana mariana are you here yes you're
safe
I can't believe me you told me where to
hide I just listened to what you said oh
[ __ ] yourself in and don't come out not
even once it's quiet it kept running
through my head like on a loop you did
exactly what you should have done I
always knew you were smart kid Thanks
but you didn't listen now once the
rebels couldn't see them anymore they
just passed by Jeep and your brother
where are they we got pulled apart when
that huge bunch of muerto showed up kate
yalda they were gonna try to make it
back to the van and that's where we're
headed let's go find your brother
sweetheart I'm mr. biking no no don't
Matt me oh [ __ ] that was our deal
sorry Clemmy oops no no sign of them
they must have seen it like this then
going someplace else to hide
cheap could that be here oh it's them
how about that Arianna stay back a
grenade will do the trick right oh it's
fighting time maybe it's a [ __ ] and Tim
Oh Oh God you got snoop down that one
look like a kid oh [ __ ]
hey how about thing they're all then
you're welcome javi you found us yes but
I have another girlfriend now so don't
worry about it I got you you happy to
see me me oh oh okay all right
come on I think we get a pass
all right I wanted to come after you I
swear I did you don't have to snot all
over my shirt about it I thought we were
dead like never gonna see you again dead
we only had a couple bullets left
there's no way I would let that happen
yeah well you weren't here well I got
her to showed up and Mariana was gone
and we were waiting and waiting and then
I was just so scared are you then you
dumb you don't have to be scared
Hey you hurt yourself
must have scraped you in the truck
didn't even notice um Lisa it's not a
bite or is it no not much we can do
about it here I've got a lady friend
who's a doctor soon as we get back to
Prescott
she'll patch you right up I'm trip by
the way pleasure to make your
acquaintance and let's go on a trip
you're ever getting back don't want to
push your luck who's the kid with the
gun she's not a king of a name you want
to share with us or are you gonna make
me do my own introductions clementines a
friend hi there
glad I was able to help well we're very
grateful to you
really there's a town nearby it's safe I
like the sound of that
so emotional climate nah hey hot water
even like lukewarm water would be okay
ah and bubble bath what a bubble bath be
amazing I think so right trip well I
guess you'll find out I thought you'd
been to this place I have I just didn't
have much time to relax in my jacuzzi
suite you know between you and me these
kinds of missions don't usually go so
well but you found every single one of
your people and you found him alive
healthy reasonably cheerful and let's
wait to celebrate until we're back
behind the walls okay I want to jinx us
well some things are worth saying
whoo-hoo about that's all when we get
back to Prescott you still owe me a
working ride I haven't forgotten about
our deal you couldn't have known what
happened to your van but still I need
some way out of here
that van was the only ride I had a lead
on so maybe it's time to renegotiate I
know it's not the easiest thing to find
but cool the ambulance
you really need to just throw those away
okay and then I have the battery I mean
I have the thing Thanks Oh
what boat oh [ __ ]
you jinxed it Eugene said all right I
don't think so
papi we can't leave her
[ __ ]
stop stop No
you guys are dumb oh my god I gotta
cover them right Leon no not Leon go
Lonnie Lonnie whatever not Lonnie anyone
but money
Jesus Jesus I'm so just I know Bobby and
there'll be time for all that but not
right now Kate needs a doctor which
means we got to go we got a window here
man we gotta get a move on before they
start shooting again I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill him I'm gonna kill all of them you
want to die too
you think that's gonna help your little
girl what I'm just supposed to let him
live if you want to do what's right for
your family you come with me it's time
to go man
stay here and finish this are you
[ __ ] here claiming time your family
again let trip help them you stay with
me
what no Bobby you have to come with us
Bobby please trust me hobby we have to
end this now get her back to Prescott
we'll cover you Bobby go with them
I'll be fine give me a hand here kid
just keep firing until they're out of
sight okay I'm ready
papi don't
that was episode 1 - that man oh oh that
was awesome that was so sure that was
just one hour less that was almost just
an hour that's that's probably why they
like we have we have another so dang
[ __ ] god I understand that why people
would be like what the [ __ ] I waited for
this that's cool though did you stay the
night at the junker you and 56
okay well alright did you shoot the
driver Oh a lot of people a lot of
people decided to shoot huh I would have
imagined that people let him go but he
was such an [ __ ] I didn't like him
and I got to prove myself to klimkin
eighty-eight percent of players got
locked up huh okay well fair enough who
brought you to the junkyard everyone
decided with their dick and balls huh
alright fair enough did you escape with
your family or stay with Clementine
that's an obvious one come on easy of
course I'll stay with Clementine alright
very cool I am so glad that we have two
more episodes that we can play I mean
it's one of my episode but I'll split it
into two I love playing this game I am
so glad it's back you know it's [ __ ]
back I'm so excited it's so cool to see
how clementines character has developed
it's so cool to be back in the universe
that is more interesting it's it seems
listen I don't know episode 2 was a
little whiny and monie okay
I am I the only one that got that well
I'm everything there's so bad here
things is moving forward you can tell
that the universe has expanded into in
different ways we should I think it's
really awesome but yeah leave a like if
you enjoy watching I'll see you tomorrow
with episode 2 we're lucky huh Thank You
telltale you [ __ ] rock man that's
once just for you man I think I'm I've
been shooting a lot on the other
telltale ones but I'm just honest okay
I think I think this one was really good
and they deserve praise right so it's
always stay awesome press